[Music]
if every spoon of rice you eat from a
styrofoam box
is toxic to your health and takes days
away from your lifespan would you still
eat from it
should we fix this problem through
design
i think as designers it's really
important to always be
on top of sustainability and have it as
one of our key values
i would say in the last decade there's
been a shift in thinking
from linear product system to more
circular
design system and it's this notion that
you know we should not be
just looking at designing a product
prototyping it
selling it end of story but rather we
have to really look at the whole
ecosystem in a more holistic manner
right from where was the material
sourced from is it farmed or produced in
a sustainable way
right to how we produce it how we sell
it and after the consumer use it
where does it get discarded how do the
cities manage the waste in that manner
and who should be responsible for this
circular system
[Music]
as we all know pulau samaka which is a
landfill for all the
toxic waste that's come from the
incineration is gonna fill up in 2035
so there is urgency right now to reduce
waste
i recall we were at a point in our
professional practice when we wanted to
recalibrate our focus
we were thinking about what we really
care about and how we can make our
design practice
align closer to the purpose that drives
us on a daily basis and i think we're
thinking a lot about nature
so we chose the representation of nature
that
for us is important in singapore which
is a forest and the same in argentina
which is the whales
because we went on a whale-watching trip
there's no real divide between working
together professionally and living a
life together
as a family we come from completely
different cultures with different
traditions and that makes our daily life
more interesting
and it also brings a lot of value to our
professional practice
design is a lens through which you can
see the world and
is a catalyst for change many times
design is done by
to be an engineer would be a factory
owner any layman
can produce design if you look around
you you have a lot of objects that
we're using on a daily basis from the
plastic bag that holds your kopio when
you take away drinks
to the kopitiam cups or the kopitang
chair that we are also familiar with
but we may not know who designed it we
call this anonymous design
design that is really for good
functionality and a good user experience
container
so at the very beginning of every
project we we always start off with
some human centric design methods and
it's critical for us to
understand what are the needs of the
user to even reframe the design brief to
understand
where the opportunities are where the
problem statement is
for this particular project where we are
redesigning food packaging to reduce
single-use plastic
we went into the food centres we were
looking at gestures
behaviors around the way we eat how we
take away we're also looking at the
needs of not just the consumers but also
the food vendors the hawkers how do they
actually pack the food
and how can we design containers that
would better fit their actions and their
gestures so that's easier for them
because if they buy into
that shift in their behavior then they
can also become advocates for
more sustainable systems and the
research that we conduct goes beyond
just
individual users but we also look at the
entire ecosystem there's definitely some
of the gestures that we were studying
that will make a big difference too yeah
even to understanding the
economics of it because at the end of
the day for any of these solutions to be
implemented they have to make financial
sense and
if you come up with a very nice shape
that is very expensive and you cannot
scale it up then it's just not going to
work
so as part of the research is human
centered then
understanding the business or the
finances behind and with all that then
we
kind of have a few brainstorming
sessions where we have all the data that
we collected we have images
to remind us of some specific gesture or
moments in the research from there we
will start sketching come up with some
ideas
quickly prototype them so we can bring
them back to
the user and i guess the reason for the
prototypes is for user testing
especially in this case
when we prototype the the food packaging
we can bring it to the food vendors we
can
use it ourselves and basically keep
testing and seeing how that works
it's the same when we design furniture
we will have the chair prototype in our
place or our studio
for months and anyone who enter would
sit on it and give us some feedback so
to kind of have the time
to let that prototype be used be tested
manufacturing part of design is really
important
the craftsman that is doing what you
design is is a key player and you have
to work with them
adjust the design to have the perfect
use of their
technology then one thing we have to
improve is the
the closing system now is is a bit weak
so we have to make something that is a
bit easier to close
we always visit factories and when we do
chairs we visit carpentries
and that really informs us and helps us
save time
as we develop new projects
[Music]
so designers are storytellers and when
we finish designing a product
we have to start thinking about how to
tell the story and how to tell it
creatively to the wider audience
we do it through you know photography
film
and sometimes even publications so we do
spend quite a bit of time writing
because
sometimes the publication can last
longer than the product itself
and some of the messages and stories or
philosophy can go a long way
in advocating change or in communicating
an idea
and and and seeing how that kind of
build a legacy for the product so from a
designer point of view
our responsibilities in ensuring that
whichever product we design
is easy to disassemble whether it is for
repair or for recycling collaborate with
material scientists to
see what are the better alternatives
that we can use in our case we are
working with
a range of companies on edible materials
we are exploring options with
algae-based materials we are working
with a company
to bring edible container that is made
of wheat so this
initial part of the design process which
is getting the right material or
trying to innovate in new materials is
really important to have a good outcome
yeah i think designers play a very
important role in designing for circular
systems because we understand
how materials can be developed when we
work with material scientists
how factories work how productions work
we can understand what are the user
needs or how can we design for user
needs and we also deal with the
communication
to the users when it comes to the
products that we design so we have that
good overview and that's why we can play
the role very well as facilitators of
the various stakeholders within this
circular system
and i think this is a road that's very
important for for designers to play in
the future
our planet is not going to improve
unless we take action
if you could advocate change through
design would you
[Music]
you